women who cry about equality and ceo
positions never address the fact that
those positions are a zero-sum game
meaning
someone must lose for another one to get
it where's the quality no equality for
that hard work and dangerous jobs
careful your privilege is showing what
do you think of that
i do think um
i know personally if i see your job as a
very difficult job yeah personally i
wouldn't want to be in that country
because i know what kind of work it
takes like you're going to be available
all the time answering emails holidays
and stuff that's kind of not my world
but like if someone's going to go into
that like oh like as a woman i'm just
going to get this job because i'm a
woman i've worked hard but just because
i'm a woman i should have the extra edge
yeah
i don't know if that i don't know if
that counts like i think there's minimal
things like you know that uh thing you
had where it's like women in coding and
stuff like
small things but when it comes to ceo i
don't think there are things that are
like positions for women in seattle like
ceo that's like you've got here will
give you a chance i don't think those
top positions i have those kind of again
i'm not like
i think they do
i think that when like like people want
women in positions of power so they can
market it
like you realize 80 of consumer buying
decisions are made by women also women
hold 80 of like credit card debt
like women so everything we see in
society is like constantly being
marketed to women for women
like do you do you think like men want
to see like plus size girls
that's what i mean like yeah like i
personally don't know a lot about that
what do you mean plus i said girls like
in advertisements yeah like that's for
women that's not for men like when
politicized women are modeling it's
normally for women's clothes so i'm not
sure if that would appeal to a man
anyway like it's a bikini oh for sure
for sure
and then that gets into it yeah but yeah
but they get they go to the cover of
like even sports illustrated
experience is different like um i don't
know but i like sports and plus size i'm
not sure like i haven't met many
plus-size athletes before so i'm not
sure like yeah which is no my only point
is that like everything we see in the
market is for women so
i would guess and this is this isn't
this is just you know feeling not based
on data or anything like if there was a
male ceo and a woman ceo they would pick
the woman because they can market that
especially if they're a big company
like bumble like the whitney whatever
her name is yeah she only owns like 10
of the company and they all talk about
she's a female ceo yeah
yeah